thanks to the exciting news from James
Gunn about the future of DC Studios
you've probably heard of Supergirl woman
of Tomorrow singled out as one of The
Inspirations for the first chapter of DC
Studios storytelling the eight issue
Adventure by Tom King and Bill Chris
Everly immediately became a must read
for fans curious about where DC's New
Cinematic Universe is going but DC
Comics fans will tell you this was a
pivotal story for the girl of steel
before it was an instant sensation
writer Tom King recently said on Twitter
Supergirl was a small ambitious book
that got out there and got attention
because of the passion of all the fans
who took a chance read it and shared it
Supergirl woman of Tomorrow spans the
stars in a Sci-Fi tale that will forever
change how you think about Kara zorel so
let's go on a weekend escape to a far
away world where a red Sun hangs low in
the sky as The Story begins the premise
a young girl on a a distant planet seeks
revenge when her unarmed father is
murdered by the merciless Creme of the
yellow Hills her furious quest for
vengeance begins in a nearby town where
her path unlikely enough crosses with
Supergirl Kara zorel and crypto came to
a planet with a red Sun to celebrate her
21st birthday with a drink or several
but when she meets a girl who feels like
she's lost her whole world Cara can't
let her go on alone they embark on an
epic journey together that will leave
them both forever changed now let's talk
Talent Tom King the writer of Batman Mr
Miracle the human target and the sheriff
of Babylon and so much more is already
considered a Comics Legend the Eisner
Award winner has taken many of your
favorite superheroes on genre spanning
Odysseys that shape them into fallible
complicated characters Supergirl is no
exception joining King for this series
is artist Bill quis Everly evely has
worked on Wonder Woman and the dreaming
in the Sandman Universe her distinctive
detailed art is both evocative and
otherworldly a perfect for the
Extraterrestrial settings of women of
Tomorrow combined with Matthew's Lopez's
kaleidoscopic colors the art in this
limited mini-series is nothing short of
extraordinary now let's talk about a few
reasons to read 1. Ruthie Mary Knoll
woman of Tomorrow is just as much
Ruthie's story as it is Kara's she's
young but she's also determined and
undeterred she's wise enough to give
Supergirl the space she needs to cope
with the gruesome Horrors they encounter
on nameless planets and Cara saves the
young girl's Life Time and Time Again
Naturally
also there for Cara whether
holding a throw-up bucket after Cara's
red sunbender or protecting the
powerless Kryptonian when an entire
world is intent destroying her
2. Kara zorel is more than simply Cal
Al's cousin much much more they might be
related but Superman and Supergirl are
not the same person there's a hardness
to Cara that's explored more in this
state she fights for truth and justice
but she fights her way
seeing Cara through Ruthie's eyes give
the story a sense of unflinching honesty
about the character that Cara's own
narration might not have otherwise
provided three Supergirl's origin story
is more harrowing than you ever realized
Cara experienced more loss by the age of
14 than most do in a lifetime and it
wasn't just when Krypton exploded the
resulting Devastation immediately spared
her City but the casualties continued
for months after Cara watched her
remaining people slowly die before she
left her terminally ill father to follow
her cousin to Earth this retelling of
Supergirl's origin is horrific and raw
adding new depth to The Familiar
character you thought you knew
4. the Galaxy is a dangerous and highly
compelling place there are endless
stories to be told across the stars in
the DC Universe and until I read woman
of tomorrow I never considered how many
lowlifes living among the Stars would
hold a grudge against Superman and his
friends
they don't know what they're in for
now here's why it's worth your time
it's exciting to think we'll be getting
a big screen version of this
breathtaking book but the producers sure
have their work cut out for them
Supergirl woman of Tomorrow takes
readers on a cosmic Journey while
accentuating a fundamental truth about
Kara zorel she is a badass with or
without superpowers it's impossible to
read this series and not come away from
it with a new appreciation for the
maiden of Might Cara isn't just
Superman's cousin she's complex tough
and unbreakable no matter what
Abominations the Galaxy throws at her
and after you read woman of tomorrow
you'll never forget that Supergirl woman
of Tomorrow by Tom King and Bill kiss
evely is now available to read in full
on DC Universe infinite and in print as
a graphic novel
this originally appeared as a dc.com
weekend Escape feature written by Kelly
Knotts Kelly Knox writes about all ages
comics and animation for DC comics.com
and her writing can also be seen on IGN
Nerdist and more follow Kelly on Twitter
at Kelly underscore Knox to talk
superheroes comics and pop culture and
of course the views and opinions
expressed in this feature are solely
those of Kelly Knox and do not
necessarily reflect those of DC
entertainment or Warner Brothers nor
should they be read as confirmation or
denial of future DC plans
[Music]